three out of five possessions instead of
the net all the time and i think that's
their responsibility because as much as
kenny you're right because when when
they get a rebound they're looking for
him he starts doing that right away no
no no man
i'm gonna lock you off
listen what i said your star is supposed
to bring you home but like
i'm not going to the star like i used to
tell kevin and dan marley hey y'all do
y'all know i would say this chuck if we
go back to tapes of you no you wait
he's going to be like this sometime and
they're going to be looking you off
because the responsibility kevin was
like no i can't do that every time and
some that's their responsibility to look
you up dave martin
dan marlar he never looked my way he's
going to get it up
yeah
the series is tied to a piece of phoenix
by the way in those two games in dallas
did not lead in the second third or
fourth quarters of either of those games
uh the john morant story now
uh yo man these guys i'm getting really
i'm getting sick of the nba right now
grizzlies got beat badly by golden state
last night and done jaw was yeah that
messes me up with that play
that played yeah yeah and they and they
were complaining about it taylor jenkins
complaining
i'm getting a little sick man i'm sick
of these today's players everything
ain't no cold
and taylor jacobs
probably a real good chance he won't
play tomorrow
in game four of that series and jared
says look i've been told by the league
uh they reviewed the boy someone told
him that the league reviewed the pool
morant play at the request of the
grizzlies it's been determined come on
man it was a normal basketball player no
further action
[Music]
show it again because there you can see
that he reaches but
yeah yeah reached out to basketball in
the basketball game
we don't have to review everything in
the nba now watch again did he pull his
kneecap back or something
that's not man come on he didn't try to
stop it nobody trying to hurt him
well jaw in fact tweeted out
that play and said broke the code taking
what steve kerr said about the dylan
brooks
and then he and then he deleted the and
i disagreed with steve kerr you think uh
adalence was a code
uh i thought he didn't try to hurt that
somebody answered my question did he
pull his kneecap out of the place they
haven't told us shaq i mean they don't
look like they're coming listen uh
listen dylan brooke that was a flagrant
too but the the notion he tried to hurt
that kid i'm not gonna live with that
and now they're trying to complete this
is the cold
man give me a break man y'all
man
are you getting frustrated chuck
straight every call ernie are you
watching the basketball game let's see
if it's a flagrant let's see if it's a
flagrant wonderful i'm like yo man that
i've been kissed harder than that well
we don't know about your sex life we
just talk about the fact that
he's telling you you know what you said
the two magic words yeah next life we'll
be back
geez
it was nice
[Music]
chipotle's all-new pollo asado starts
with fresh grilled chicken hand-cut
cilantro